>>So without further ado, please join us in
welcoming Kelly.
Kelly: Hi, thank you so much for having me.
Um, this is my first novel, as Lindsey mentioned,
and it is the story about Louisa May Alcott
and it's set in 1855 when, um -- long before
she became a famous writer -- so we know she's
most famous for writing Little Women. How
many of you have read or the movie or knows
the story of little women. Um it is about
the four March sisters Meg, Jo, Beth and Amy
and they live in Massachusetts and their father
is a chaplain and away in the civil war. So
they are at home with their mother and this
is a difficult time for the March family because
they um are poor and the the head of their
household is away and so they really have
to become little women, as the title says
they have to learn to take responsibility
and come together as a family to get through
this difficult time. Um, and this novel was
first published in 1868 and it made her very
famous. It became and overnight success. She
went from being a nobody to being very rich
and um, they wanted her to publish a sequel
right away, which she did. Um, and her writing
career took off from there. She was about
35 years old when she wrote Little Women,
so she had had a long road leading up to that
point of wanting to be a writer, wanting to
be, wanting fame, wanting money because she
grew up very poor. Little Women is autobiographical
in that her childhood was very much like the
March sisters and actually much more difficult
than the March sisters. Um, she sort of put
a rose-colored view on, on what their life
was like in little women. Um, so she welcomed,
originally, or initially she welcomed the
fame and the money that having published Little
Women brought her, but she grew to feel more
conflicted about it because Little Women [skips]
was a story written for young women, and it
was sort of, she called it a moral path. It
was a, you know, a moral tale, she didn't
think of it as being sophisticated writing,
she didn't think of it as being a complex
story. And she really wanted to be a novelist
who wrote for adults. So, she felt that Little
Women sort of pidgeon-holed her in her writing.
That she could not write the kind of things
that she wanted to write. She later went on
to write many hundreds of stories under a
pseudonym. There were things she wrote that
were never published during her lifetime because
they were too sensational and they were published
in the 1990s. We're still finding about stories
that we don't realize were written by her,
under different names, so there's a really
fun sort of literary detective story about
um discovering a group of stories that they
had always believed was this A.M. Barnard
and no one could figure out who A.M. Barnard
was and these two women eventually uncovered
that this was Louisa May Alcott. So, that's
a whole different story -- but she was a -- she
was a fascinating person in many ways. But,
she sort of came to feel more conflicted about
having written Little Women, and the fame
and the attention. People would come to her
house. Um, little girls, or not little girls,
young women who read Little Women loved the
character of Jo, most people always say Jo
was their most favorite because she was a
tomboy, she wanted to be a writer, she was
passionate and wanted to be independent at
a time when that wasn't an option or that
wasn't what was expected for women. She's
just a heroine in American literarure. Um,
so little girls loved her and wanted to know
more about her story and they would come to
Louisa's house and knock on the door expecting
to meet Jo because they knew that Louisa was
based, based Jo on herself. Um, and they would
be, the look of disappointment on their face
when she would open the door, because she
was older than they expected her to be and
she couldn't stand that disappointment. So,
she eventually started to say that she was
the maid and that Louisa had gone into town
and then [laughter] they might have to try
back later, so there, it was a, it was a wonderful
thing that just happened to her, but also
it brought all kinds of things into her life
that she never would have imagined. Um, she
became very famous, like I said and she was
known, and this is, this is all the stuff
I'm telling you now is the true facts of her
biography. She is known to have burned letters
and journals, because she knew that when she
died that someone would go through all her
papers and want to write about her or tell,
you know she would she was a celebrity in,
in Massachusetts. So, um, so she burned things
that she didn't or blacked out, there were
sections that she blacked out of her journal
that she didn't want of things she maybe didn't
want people to know. So, when I was reading
about her life because I was alway a Little
Women fan and then I started to read about
her biography I was very intrigued by that
thought of what could have been in these letters
and journals that she would want to hide.
And so that was some, a seed, seed in my mind.
And then um, I was thinking about what um,
the character of Laurie from Little Women
and I don't know how well you know the story
but Laurie is Teddy Lawrence, the boy, a lot
of people that don't know the, Little Women,
they think it's a girl. Laurie was a nickname
for Teddy Lawrence, and he lived next door.
He was the son of a wealthy family and became
a friend of the March sisters in the story
of Little Women and especially a friend of
Jo. Um, and they were, sort of, kindred spirits.
They had this wonderful friendship and the
book starts when they're young and as they
grow older and as a reader, you begin to think
or you're allowed to think all along that
they are going to end up together because
they have this wonderful friendship and he
doesn't expect Jo to, you know, reign in her
passionate temperment and he loves her, the
way that she is, independent and he, he, they
have an equal partnership and you can imagine
them having a kind of a unconventional, truely
loving friendship kind of marriage that would
have been rare for that time. So you're cheering
them on the whole way. He goes away to college,
he comes back, he's all in a snoot because
he's realizing he's in love with her. He sits
her down and tells her, you know, it's so
obvious, it should be us, we should be together,
you know let's get married. And she says no.
And that is a terrible let down for a lot
of people when they read that book the first
time. It's your first introduction to heartbreak
when you [laughter] read that story. Um, because
you look at the book and you say, what? This
is not what I thought was going to happen
here. And um, Louisa May Alcott got, because
she wrote Little Women in two parts, so um,
the first part ended with this sort of cliff
hanger notion of yes, there's something there
that's going to develop and they wanted her
to write the sequel. So, she wrote the sequel,
now we, now they're published together as
one book, The Little Women that we know is
actual, was two separate books. But she got
letters, and letters and letters from fans
while she was writing the second half. Please
let Jo and Laurie end up together. Please
let them get married, um, you know, this is
th most wonderful romance. But she, Louisa
did not want them to end of together because
Luisa May Alcott was staunchly independent
and felt a sense of responsibility writing
for young women readers that she wanted to
show them that that wasn't necessarily the
only choices that they had. And in the 1860's,
1870's, it was not easy to be an unmarried
woman, and you know, you didn't have a lot
of rights in terms of, you know economic or
rights and and opportunities for work. But
she, she wanted to be an example and wanted
the story to be an example for young women.
That they could pursue other things. So she
chose to write the story where Jo says no.
And Jo says she wants to stay friends and
it would, she would be afraid it would ruin
their friendship and eventually Jo does marry
a professor who is much older than her and
it's a very passionless -- you know, they
like each other, he's alright -- but geez,
it wasn't anything like Laurie, you know.
[laugher] It's definitely a let down as the
reader. Um, because her publisher basically
told her she had to have Jo marry someone;
she couldn't end the book with, with Jo just
keep, keeping her independence. So, um, so
that's the other thing I was thinking about.
So I was thinking about the burning of the
letters and journals and I was also thinking
about Laurie, because in Little Women, all
the sisters correspond to Louisa's real sisters,
her mother was very much like her real mother,
not exactly, but a lot in some ways like her.
The father is not really there but what we
know of him in the story is a lot like Louisa
May Alcott's real father, but the character
of Laurie is a little mysterious. Um, Louisa
said at different times that he was based
on two different young men that she met in
her life, a neighbor and a man she met when
she traveled in Europe. Uh, but it's never
really a satisfying explanation. So, my idea
was to think about what could be in these
letters and journals that she was going to
burn and what if there was a real person who
inspired the character of Laurie and then
she decided to erase him from the record.
So that was the basis for for this story.
Um, I guess I could read a little bit, is
that good? Okay. Just take a drink. Do you
have any questions about that stuff so far?
>>Not yet.
Kelly: Okay, hate to put you on the spot.
So, my story takes place in um, the summer
of 1855; she wrote Little Women in 1868, so
this was long before she's had any success
as a writer. She is living still with her
family. They lived most of their childhood
in Concord, Massachesetts and Boston. Um,
but they often struggled financially because
Bronson, the father, was an very ineffective
provider. He was a transcendental philosopher,
he was a man of ideas and words and of books
and not a very, and he actually objected philophically
to the idea of commerce. So, he did not engage
in any acts of commerce that was left to his
wife to figure out how to put food on the
table and get them a roof over their head.
And so they were often moving around, um,
and this particular summer they lived in Walpole,
New Hampshire because their, the mother had
a house that belonged to her brother-in-law,
or he gave them this house for the summer.
So they were able to live there for free.
So, Louisa and her older sister Anna and Lizzy
and May were the two younger sisters and the
mother and father go to Walpole. So they had
just arrived in the town and the house was
kind of a mess because no one's been living
in it. So there's mold everywhere and they've
got to clean it out and they've got to put
curtains on the windows so Louisa and Anna
are walking into town to buy fabric. That's
what's happening here. And it's on page 16
if you want to follow along. I feel like I'm
leading a class [laughter].
"Louisa had been to Walpole only once before,
when she was quite young, so she tries not,
or she tries to notice each store front and
memorize it's contents to report back to her
mother. The sisters were experienced at moving.
As children they lived in several different
houses, and they knew all about the work each
move made for the women. Stocking the kitchen,
dressing the windows, planting a new vegetable
garden. It helped to get the lay of the land
and meet the shop keepers early, especially,
Louisa thought with dread, since they would
soon be testing the shop keeper's generosity
buy asking to buy things on credit. As they
descended the hill, they turned West on Middle
Street and then North into Washington Square,
where the town's few shops were clustered.
The butcher shop occupied the southwest corner
of the square. Bronson's aversion to meat
made Anna and Louisa a little skiddish about
the carcasses hanging in the windows and they
looked away as they passed by. The square
contained two village book stores that were
local centers of political discussion. On
the west side of the square, men interested
in the philosophy of the waning Whig party
argued over what to do about slavery and how
modern technology, like railroads may change
the country. Directly opposite, on the east
side of the square, Democrats stood with their
arms crossed, thumb pensively fingering their
beards as they lamented the death of the ideallic
farming society President Jefferson had envisioned
in their grandfather's time. And men who cared
for neither politics nor books gather at the
tavern that sat between the stores to imbibe
and gamble until their wives prevailed upon
them to return home for supper. Abba was at
least lucky on one account. And Abba is Louisa's
mother, Abigail. Bronson was a temperate man
and never once set foot in that place of temptation.
Louisa fought back the whelling irritation
that made her jaw feel tight. Walpole seemed
to her wholly unremarkable. Over the last
few years, she had felt herself growing restless,
yearning for freedom from the domestic obligations
that came with continuing to live at home.
Though the cares of Boston frightened her,
the noise and heat of the train, the looming
shadow of steamers discharging immigrants
on Indian Wharf where vendors sold peppered
oyster soaked in vinegar near the overcrowded
tenements. She loved th excitement and freedom
of the city. With her family she had bounced
between Boston and Concord over the years,
but never had the chance to live in a city
on her own, to have the space and time to
think and write. Since her father had announced
the solution to their current financial whoas,
his plan was to move the family here to Walpole,
Louisa had been scheming for a way to get
back to the city as soon as possible. She
had promised herself she would accompany them
to her uncle's house, help unload the trunk
and be on the first train from Bellows Falls
back to Boston by the end of the week. She
still had most of the money left from the
$10 she earned for The Rival Prima Donna,
a story she wrote under the name of Flora
Fairfield and the advance on Flower Fables,
her collecton on fairy tales published in
a tiny local run the previous fall. The publisher
had sent her a mere $32 for that work, though
even this small sum had astonished her at
the time. She gave a portion to her father
for the good of the household and squirreled
the rest away professing an oath to Anna and
her mirror that she would safeguard the money
for one express purpose. 'I, Louisa Alcott,
do swear,'
'Do solomonly swear', Anna offered. Her hands
cradeling the green leather bible on which
Louisa rested her palm.
'Do solomonly swear to resist temptations
large and small, be they in the form of particularly
bewitching bonnets, slippers...'
'Gloves?', Anna asked with her eyebrowes raised.
Louisa nodded, 'Gloves'.
And Anna was quick to test her sister's conviction.
'Even if they happen to be the sort that close
with those tiny pearl buttons?'
'Especially if they have pearl buttons, as
well as chocolates, pecans, new books, fine
pens...'
'And cream laid writing paper, don't forget
about that. Anna pressed her lips together
to suppress a smile.
Louisa groaned and closed her eyes, 'The very
thought of it tests me this moment. Yes, yes,
no fine writing paper. Now, where was I? Oh
yes, resist temptations large and small so
noted, in the service of my especial aim,
to secure for myself in the City of Boston,
a place apart and and a room in which I might
write my stories and sell them to the highest
bidder.'
'Well done', cried Anna, and the oath was
sealed."
So, in this part of the story, of course,
Louisa's thinking it's going to be very simple.
She's going to get them set up in the house.
She's going to get on the train to freedom;
but of course, that does not work out that
way. So, that's my shpeel, I would love to
hear questions, if you have any.
>>How did you prepare to write this? Like
what kind of research did you do, and how
long does that take?
Kelly: It was um, it I researched for about
6 months before I actually started thinking
about how I wanted to write it, or which story
I wanted to tell, because there was so much
about her life, that was amazing and fascinating
to me. And I wanted it all to be in the novel
but it wouldn't all fit in one story. So I
had to decide what I wanted to focus on, what
part of her life I wanted to focus on. Um,
I thought a lot about how she is such a historical
icon to us, you know. Um, what do we really
know about her? We know she wrote Little Women,
that's what most people know. Um, but she
had this whole other life, and and I wondered
too about what is it like to be the kind of
person who did something that, you know this
book has never gone out of print, thousands
and thousands and thousands of women have
read this book over decades. So, what is it
about her that her do this and did she know
about herself, that she had this in her destiny.
Or was she just a normal person before this
came into her life. So, I, that's why I decided
to set it before, so that, you know, thinking
of what she, who, who the Louisa person was.
Um, but in terms of research, I read all the
biographies of her, a lot of biographies of
her family. Her father, like I said was a
philosopher, Ralph Waldo Emerson was their
neighbor, Nathaniel Hawthorne was their neighbor,
Thoreau was their neighbor.
>>Oh my gosh!
Kelly: Uh huh. Concord, Concord was the most
important place to be in the 1850's; um, in
terms of writing and thinking in American
philosophy. And she, Thoreau, I have some
things about Thoreau in here, he used to take
her on nature walks in the woods, she learned
all about the natural world from Thoreau.
Emerson was her father's best friend, so he
was often at the house. He read Louisa's rough
drafts of her work and gave her feed-back
on her writing when she was young. Um, so
they lived in a very interesting place. Um,
so reading biographies of them, and then my
favorite part of the historical research is
um, learning about how they lived their lives
day-to-day. That is just fascinating to me.
How did, how they made candles. I have a scene
in here where Anna and Louisa are making candles.
And so learning how they did that; and, you
know, what supplies you would use and where
they would get them from and just the process
of that. Or, how they prepared their food,
what kind of you know; seasonal eating is
so popular now. Well that was what you did.
That's only what anyone did then, because
when there was not such thing as refrigerated
transport of food. Or, I mean just everything
that we take for granted. It's fascinating
to me to learn what life would have been like
day-to-day for them. So, they are many many
good books out there for learning about these
archaic things that I'm really interested
in. Um, a lot of reading, reading her letters
and journals was fascinating and a way to
understand her voice. And really think, you
know, hearing and writing her voice -- I wanted
it to be -- I want to understand her from,
from her own words. Um, so that was, she didn't
burn all the letters and journals, thank goodness,
you know, they still have a lot. She only
burned the mysterious ones. [laughter]. That
have the juicy stuff in them apparently. Um,
so I guess that would be, and then um, you
know libraries are very good places for me
to, to uh talk to librarians who know so much
and can point you in the right direction toward
sources that you wouldn't think of. Old magazines,
old newspapers. It's a fun, you know, fun
journey. Like a treasure hunt.
>>Did you do any traveling to any of these
places?
Kelly: A little bit. I didn't travel to the
town until after I wrote the first draft,
because I, I had a map, had a Google map.
[laughter] Um, of the town and I had done
enough research on the town to know the street
names, which had changed and so I could, you
know sort of have a map that was regressed
to 1855. Um and understood the layout of the
town and I knew which buildings were old enough
to have been there. But I didn't want to go
there because I knew it, well it's a modern
town now and I wanted to have the town of
my imagination be what was first in the page,
but then I knew I needed to go there to see
it and maybe there was something I was missing.
So I did go, um it happened to be when we
were traveling out to Maine for a wedding
so we drove through. And it was very interesting
going. I always tell the story about, um,
that house that they lived in is still there,
but it is an apartment complex now. And it
had, um it was just so not what I it. It is
still called Alcott House, but it, it has,
you know one of those really funky awnings
on the front, all these additions that have
come along, you know since the time. And there
was this big like '79 Chevy Impala parked
on the lawn it had a Lynard Skynard bumper
sticker. I mean [laughter] it was so not the
quaint, you know, New England house from 1855
that I pictured. So it was probably good that
I didn't go there before um. [laughter] But
it was neat to walk the same streets that
they walked and to smell what the air smells
like and the flowers and the bees and the
things that you wouldn't think of until you
really walked there. So that was, that was
really a good experience.
>>Given that you had um, so much insight into
her thoughts, via the journals and things
like that, why did you choose to write in
third person as opposed to first?
Kelly: Well, that a good question. I think
that um, I felt that that might be going a
little too far in terms of making assumptions
about her voice; or [pause] presuming to know
her so well to speak in her voice. I think
that I was a uncomfortable enough at the idea,
and I still am in some ways, of writing a
story about a real person making a fictional
story up about a real person that I think
the third person gave me enough distance that
I felt, um I wasn't presuming so much about
who she was, or understanding her. And also,
just from a practical point of view, structuring
the novel, I wanted to be able to um, see
her from the outside and be able to see other
characters from the outside that I as a narrator
would have a different perspective on them
then then she might, inside her own head.
So sometimes it can be just more of a structural
decision. But I, I definitely think that I
wanted enough distance from her voice in that
way. Does that make sense?
>>Yeah, and actually I sort of have a semi-related
question. Um, I know you said this was you
first published novel, but I imagine you've
written your own things before?
Kelly: Um hmm.
>>Um, if you've ever written a fully fictional
character versus that space in history, have
you noticed yourself behaving differently
with the character? Do you connect less with
her or more with her or?
Kelly: I think that I'm more um, it's more
freeing to write about a completely fictional
person, because you're not as worried about,
um, portraying them incorrectly or disrespectfully.
Or I mean, I admire Louisa May Alcott so immensely;
and connect with her in that, you know, I
just feel a sense of understanding about who
she was and how she felt about her work; and
what she wanted her life to be like; and her
struggle for independence and things like
that. I really can relate to those things.
But, at the same time, she was a real person.
When you create a completely fictional character,
then you can create whoever you want. And
so there's definitely a sense of responsibility
when you are writing anything about a real
person that um, and, and some people think
that you shouldn't do it at all because of
these, you know, issues and concerns. But,
um, so yes I have written other characters.
I'm writing a book right now that is a completely
fictional character and in some ways it is
easier in that it's, you feel more free to
create her in any way that you want to. But,
um I loved writing about Louisa too because
I loved learning about her life and I loved
sort of imagining, you know, bringing her
life, that was very fun. Getting, it was like
getting a conversation, it was like getting
to ask her all the questions that I really
wanted to ask her and never was able to ask
her because she's gone. But, you know writing
the story I felt like I was able to sort of
talk to her. [she laughs]. In a weird way.
>>Can you tell me a little bit more about
your process, you know what I mean, you researched
a lot, like how long did it take you for you
to write the whole novel and did you start
at the beginning and work your way all the
way to the end or.
Kelly: Um hmm.
>>Or did you piece it together? How, things
like that?
Kelly: Um, it was very different, it's very
different now than it was when it, from the
first draft. Um, originally, I wanted a story
that had a contemporary plot, with flashbacks
to the historical times. So I had a narrator
who was in the first person. Um, who was living
in Boston and working as a teacher. And I
had this whole story around her life and she
discovered at her aunt's house this trunk
that contained letters. And that her aunt
would have been a decendent of Joseph, the
love interest in the story. Um, and she would,
over time, uncover the details of this relationship
and through the letters there would be these
flashback chapters of the historical. Um,
but as I was working on it, I so loved writing
the historical portions and so dreaded kind
of [laughter] I don't know sort of this dread.
I don't know I just didn't sort of like this
character very much, didn't like where the
story was going. It was sort of like that
friend that you just wish would stop calling
you, [laughter] you know, you're tired of
hanging out with her, I don't know I just,
I think I just liked Louisa more than I liked
her. So, I ended up just, I was so frustrated
with it because I'm, I was getting to this
point where I would say, okay, Monday, Wednesday,
Friday I have to work on the, you know contemporary
plot and on Tuesday and Thursday I can work
on the historical. But then I would find ways
of avoiding it and all this stuff. I finally
had to have a sit down with myself and just
decide, what am I going to do about this 'cause
it's not working. So then I just took a break
for a while. I didn't even, I didn't know
if I would finish it, I was just so frustrated.
And then what I finally realized what I had
to do was just cut all that and restructure
the story around these few, but very lovingly
crafted themes that I had of the historical
time. And, um so that was 150 pages that I
had to cut and that was a hard day.
>>Wow.
Kelly: Because I felt like I had made so much
progress. I had all this, I had lots and lots
of pages, but it wasn't coming together as
a novel. So I cut those. I still have them,
but I mean they will never see the light of
day because I, you know, don't feel the love
for that. [laughter]. But, um, and then I
had to, you know, grow the story and develop
the story around what I did have. And decided
you know how, what to develop the sisters
more, and to make it into a novella of it's
own. So, that was a process, um, coming to
that decision and, you know, many many more
months after that of writing more. Additional
research, because once I expanded it, it raised
a lot more questions about things. Um and
so I would say, from beginning to end of sending
it out for submission, it was probably a year
and a half. Um, and it was, uh, it was a kind
of an interesting time in our lives because
we had, my husband is a physics professor
at Loyola. But he just started that job in
July. And before we moved to Chicago for that
job, he in order to be competitive for the
path of theoretical physics in academia, you
have to do well these short-term research
positions. So, we had moved around a lot to
different universities. And um, we had been
in Rhode Island for two years, which is when
I started to get really interested in um,
in the Alcotts and that part of history and
then we moved to Ontario for two years. Waterloo,
which actually there's a Google office in
Waterloo, Ontario [laughter]. Um, but we didn't
know a soul there and I was, I had been teaching
7th grade when we lived in Rhode Island, but
I couldn't teach there because my certificate
wasn't recognized. So I started working as
a nanny, which was not something I really
wanted to do, um and that was when I started
writing. So, anyway, that's a long answer
to your question. But it took a year and a
half and that was kind of the amount of time
that I had to allow it to take, because we
were there for two years, I needed something
to show for that time, I felt. And so then
I was able to submit it right around the time
that we were starting to prepare to leave
from there. So. Yeah.
>>And how long did it, can it take once you,
like how did you find a publisher and how
long did it take to actually get published?
Kelly: Um, so first you have to find an agent,
that's the first hurdle. Um, you submit to,
you know, you look for agents who are interested
in the same or represent the same kind of
works. So someone who does historical fictions
or someone who, you know, might have an interest
in this kind of thing. And um, you send a
query letter. There's a whole process. You
send a query letter, which is just a one-page
letter that's about the story. And sort of
give your marketing hook, how you think it
could be you know, portrayed to a publisher.
And then if the agent likes it, they will
request the manuscript. So then that takes
time and they read it and they decide okay,
we're going to represent you. And then, from
that point they are sending it to editors
at different publishers and that's a long
process of waiting to hear, is anyone going
to want it, it's a very tough market, yadda,
yadda, yadda. [laughter] So it can be a long
dissapointment, you know it can be a struggle.
Um, and then you finally find an editor that
is interested and then there's the whole negotiating
process and you know how long is it going
to take. So, that whole thing, I mean it actually
went pretty fast for me, a lot faster than
it does for a lot of people. I think I had
good timing with you know, people are really
interested in historical fiction right now
for some reason, it just a trend at the moment.
I mean it comes and goes, over time. Like
some people think it's because of the economy,
that people are interested in, you know, the
past and the simpler time, which of course
it's never really a simpler time. [laughter]
But, um so, for whatever reason, I was really
lucky. So it took about, you know it took
a few months from when I first sent it to
May, the woman who became my agent, until
we had the commitment from my publisher that
they wanted to publish it. And then it takes
about a year to actually come out. Because
you go through a long process of editing with
your editor and then it has to be copy edited,
the cover design and the, and you know, all
that kind of stuff. So uh it was March '09
that it was sold to the publisher and April
this last couple of weeks that it came out.
So.
>>Oh, it's brand new!
>>It is brand new. [laughter] It's brand new,
yes. So, yeah.
>>Can you tell us more about your current
project?
Kelly: Sure, um it is another historical novel.
It's set in 1835, so a little bit earlier
than this one. Um, and it starts in Buffalo,
New York. Um, it's about a woman who is in
a violent marriage, and she is trying to escape
from this marriage and two other women are
helping her. And, there are no railroads at
this time, so the only way to travel West
was just by steamship. So she takes a steamship
to Mackinac Island, because one of these women
has a house on Mackinac Island. And she's
partially based on a real person whose house
is now a, a bed and breakfast on Mackinac
Island, the Harbour View Inn. Um, so these
women help, are helping her make this escape.
And so a lot of the book takes place on Mackinac
Island, which has been really fun to research.
And it's fun to talk to people from Michigan
about that, because everybody, well not everyone,
but a lot of people have been there or know
about it. And it's kind of this gem that people
other places don't know about. And it has
so much interesting history, it was such an
important place during the War of 1812. It
was import - it was the, the center of the
fur trade. So the Jesuit missionaries were
there in the 1600's it's actually very, very,
very old settlement for this part of the country.
So, the history there, I mean you could write
50 novels about Mackinac Island, it's so interesting.
Um, and I got to go there last summer, in
June to do a little research. And that was
wonderful, though it rained the entire time
I was there.
>> Oh no!
[laughter]
Kelly: Yeah, it's hard to get around with
no cars. And, you know, it was raining the
entire time, but that's okay. If you are determined
enough you'll [laughter] get your work done.
Um, but it, you know, so that's been a fun
process. And then the, the tricky thing is
getting time to work on that while, you know
doing all this, which is really fun to talk
about it. But, of course, my mind is on that
one and now, you know, I'm just kind of juggling
those things but, um, but it's really fun.
I mean I'm doing what I've always wanted to
do and it's just kind of amazing that it's
happening to me. [laughter] You know, yeah.
>>So let me know if you've already answered.
Kelly: Sure.
>> This and I'll ask you at the end so everyone
else doesn't have to hear it again. But, how
do you go about, like choosing your topic
and like identifying like, you know, what
you want, what you want to write about. Like
you focus on historical fiction, so.
Kelly: Um hmm.
>>You know, how do you come about, like choosing?
Kelly: It's hard to choose, because there's
so many great stories to be written. And,
you know people say, where, how do, how do
you get your ideas. And it's like how do you
no get ideas? [laughter]. I can't walk down
the street without getting ideas. [laughter]
The main thing is, you know, is it a written,
is it a novel? Is it just a cool story, or
is it, could it be a novel. You know could
you make it into a novel? And um, you know,
reading, reading about places and, and different
time periods gives me lots of ideas. But it's
a good question, because it's hard to choose.
I think you find a compelling character in
a particular event, or um, who just captures
your attention, and you want to know more
about what their life might have been like.
And, in figuring out or inventing, if you
can't find the answer, what their life was
like. That's sort of how it comes, becomes
a story. And they sort of, you know you hear
them talking in your head and you think about
them a lot. And umm but there have been leads
that have turned out to not be. You know,
there are things I sort of pursued and really
took a lot of notes and thought about it a
lot but ultimately it just didn't materialize
for whatever reason. I got really interested
originally when I was writing about Mackinac
in John Astor. John Jacob Astor the fur trade
magnet who immigrated from Germany and owned
the American Fur Company, which was based
in Mackinac Island. And he was the first American
millionaire and, um, I thought, well there,
there's a story. But I think, maybe because
it was a man, I think I really love writing
about female characters and that I started
wanting to write about his wife or his daughter,
and I realized, okay, he's not doing it for
me. [laughter] You know, he's in the story
a little bit, but you know he's not the center
of the story anymore. But um, yeah, so I just,
you know I love the reading and choosing the
part and then, you have to choose and then
you have to commit. And then you can't read
other stuff. I have all these other things
that I want to read about, and I don't let
myself read because I know I'm going to get
sidetracked and want to think about that and
so. There's a part there's like the honeymoon
period, where you love your story so much,
and you love working on it and then it starts
to get, you know like a little more complicated
and bogged down, and you get to the hard part
where you don't know what your going to do
with the story and you get to a point where
you want to chuck it then you fall in love
with a new story. [laughter]. And then you
want to be with that story all the time. So
um, I think that you, you have to be committed,
just like you're committed to your partner.
You know, I'm not going to be turned away
by this eye-candy over here, I'm going to
pay attention to you [laughter] because I'm
committed to you and see it through to the
end, and you know, that's where the discipline
part comes in, I think.
>>Do you have like a group of people that
you share, you bounce your ideas off of like?
Kelly: I do. I have a couple of friends who
are writers and um, we do. Although it's kind
of interesting, I don't like to let people
read things until, I'm very perfectionistic,
so until I feel like they're really, really
ready to be shown. But, we do definitely bounce
ideas off each other. I have a friend who
is really smart about, you know, what's a
dud and what's a, what's compelling, you know
or what's a dud idea. And, and we're, we're
honest with each other. You have to have that
honesty, otherwise it's not helpful, you know,
kind of advice. If everything is so wonderful
that you tell her, then you know that she's
not telling you the truth. Uh, but um, yeah
I think you have to have that because it's
a very solitary job, most of the time, so
it's good to have other people that you can
talk to and who understand, and who are weird
like in the same way that you're weird. [laughter].
So.
>>You mentioned you have had, when you were
starting to write, you had like Monday, Wednesday,
Fridays dedicated to that one part. Did you
dedicate, like a certain amount of time per
day or were you like, I want to get through
so many pages?
Kelly: Yeah, well I have a word count goal
every day. Um, but I try, if I'm doing well
and I make my word count early, I try to still
sit there and keep working as long as I can.
Um, I write in the mornings. And I really
do try to write every day, because I, I think
I have that fear that if I stop for too long,
like this last couple of weeks has been really
creepy and I haven't been as good about my
routine. And there is that fear that it's
just going to go away and you'll, you won't
be able to come back to it. You won't be able
to you know, pick up the thread, probably
paranoia or not a real fear, you know not
a legitimate fear. But it's good to be afraid
of that because it motivates you to keep working.
And you do, you know you do have to be committed
to it. It's like any other job, you know you
just have to keep, keep working and keep going
with it, and have managable goals, too. I
mean having that word count, read it I'm thinking
I'm going to write my novel today, you know
that's too overwhelming. That's like trying
to run a marathon you know you have to just
go from one, one water station to the next
water station. [laughter].
>>What's you're word count?
Kelly: Um, 500 to 1,000. 500 when I'm just
having a rough day or I'm working on a difficult
part that I think is going to take a long
time. And, that doesn't sound like a lot,
but some days it's really hard to write 500
words. Some days it comes very easily, some
days 1,000, 2,000 comes very easily. Um, it
just depends on what part of the story you're
working on. And I, and then I do find time
to um you know, sort of outlining as I go,
or like how am I going to approach that next
chapter or, right now with my new one I'm
sort of working on resequencing chapters so
thinking about, okay, if I move this here,
then, I have to go back and change this part
because then it's not going to make sense
now. It's kind of like a house of cards, if
you move one thing, you know everything else
is dependent on that. So some of the time
is sort of spent on that macro-level stuff,
but, the actual writing yeah, 500 to 1,000
words a day. And you can write a novel in
you know, 3 months if you really wrote a thousand
words a day. But, then you would, every word
would have to be perfect from the beginning.
[laughter] So that doesn't count re-writing
and your revising and those types of things.
That's why it takes longer than that. So.
Um Hmm?
>>Do you have any, um authors that really
stuck out to you as a kid, or growing up that
has inspired you to really pursue this?
Kelly: Um hmm. Um, I love Ethan Canin, one
of my favorite. I can remember reading he
has this book called Emperor of the Air, a
short story collection. And I can remember
reading that in the library when I was probably
about 14 or 13, something like that. And it
was an adult book, but um thinking whoa, this
is different from anything I've ever read
in school and this guys is still alive and
I'm thinking wow, this is really a job that
people do and just being absolutely blown
away by him. He is and incredible writer.
Um, Lori Coleman is another writer that I
really love. She writes a, well she passed
away, but she did write many a few, you know
a handful of novels about young women and
you know I love women's stories, that's what
is compelling to me. Um, Marilyn Robinson.
[pause] [sigh] Um Alice Monroe, I really love
Alice Monroe, she has the most fabulous short
stories, so I just love to read so much. You
know? And I've always loved to read, and that's
what made me want to be a writer. Loving to
read and thinking, maybe I can do that too.
You know.
>>How, um, how have you noticed, I mean you've
probably been writing for a long time. How
have you notice that your process has changed?
Have you become more organized or concrete
or, you mentioned outlining.
Kelly: Um hmm. I think that um, I never really
thought it was a real thing that you could
do. I mean I always wanted to write. I wrote
all through school. I'd write a million reams
of bad poetry all through junior high [laughter]
and all that kind of stuff. But then when
I finished college I felt like I had to get
a a grown up job, that that wasn't a grown
up job, that you couldn't really pursue that.
Or it wasn't practical, so you know I had
all these grown up jobs that I hated. And
then, um when I decided I was going to try
to write a novel, I thought well, if I'm going
to do it, then I'm really going to do it as
a professional, you know in a professional
way. In that I would commit to finishing something
and um, writing something that I thought other
people would actually want to read. You know
thinking about the audience is a big step
forward from writing terrible poetry all through
junior high. Please God let no one read it.
If I'm going to burn anything it should be
that. [Laugher] If I get hit by a bus after
this meeting I won't have anyone read it.
But um, I think that um, so thinking about
it as a real job. Then it was like okay, if
you're going to try this, then let's do it
for real. And committing to a schedule and
then you know, finishing. Because a lot of
people will start things and then not finish
them. And then that's such a shame because
you put all this work and effort into it,
but it, you don't give yourself a fair shot
if you don't finish it. And you can't submit
to an agent if it's not finished. So, um,
I was going to finish it, no matter how bad
it was, I was going to finish it. And, I was
going to write every day and just really give
it a fair shot. So I think my process has
changed in that I learned to think of it as
a job. And um, to take responsibility for
it that way, and not look at it like a hobby.
I wanted to elevate it from hobby to job.
To a profession. And um, and then in terms
of, I do outline. I, you know, when you take
writing -I don't know how many of you took
writing classes in college- but outlining
and stuff is like oh, real writers don't outline
because they are just, God's word is coming
directly through them. You know the inspiration,
you know the outlining is for amateurs or
something, but actually most writers I know
do outline at least, you know, very generally.
It might not be very specific. It might not
be in Chapter One this happens, but they have
an idea when they, they have a destination.
I mean they have an idea they set out and
I think too, you know, lots of notes and part
of the historical stuff is helpful to me to
just all of the details. It's sort of like,
um you know a framework or something that
I can rely on when I'm facing that blank page
to think about, you know what's going to come
next in the story. It's good to have a little
bit of an idea of where you're headed. Some
people though like the process of just, not
knowing at all and, and going through it with
their eyes open and just ready to seize on
just whatever comes along and I think that
can work for some people too, but it might
take a lot longer to finish because you may
go down a lot of roads that won't come to
where you want to end up, and so then you
might have to circle back and loose a lot
of material, but some people enjoy that, you
know. So I think that everyone has to figure
out for themselves what they think is the
best way to do it for themselves. But, for
me, I do keep lists and outlines and I kind
of know how it's going to end, but the middle
is what, the part that I still have to figure
out as I go. But the, I kind of know where
they're all going to end up. And sometimes
I change it as I go, but.
[pause]
>>You have a question?
>>I do. [laughter] [inaudible]. Um, I was
wondering, in terms of, I mean I've read books
and literally been like bawling in my room,
you know. So when you write a book, and you
create these characters, and you like march
them into these situations, are, do you feel
like you're more connected to them because
you did it, or less connected.
>>Kelly, Um hmm, yes.
>>Because I imagine a director of a movie
doesn't thinks a scary movie is scary as their
filming it. You know, so.
Kelly: That's a really good question. That's
a really good question. I think um, when you're
working on you know, the technical aspects
of it, like getting a scene just right or
getting the word choice just right, you're
kind of in it in that way and so it's maybe
like a director, where you're not, you're
not thinking of them as real people. But when
you're working on the story and you realize
what's going to happen to one of them or you
what you have to do because it's like the
only thing that makes sense or it's the come
uppance that they need to get or whatever.
That is hard, I mean there are definitely
times where I've sat there and cried, realizing,
oh, this is going to be so sad. [laughter]
You know, because they are like real people
to you. And um, or to me anyway. But the one
I'm working on now has a lot of, um well this
one too was sad, because I knew how it had
to end. I won't tell you, because that would
be. I mean it's sort of, you sort of know
because we know about Louisa May Alcott. That
she was not married in her life, so, you know
I knew I couldn't depart from history completely
and say she marries this guy and they lived
happily ever after. And it's a totally different
ending than the real historical record. We
couldn't do that. So, um, so that was hard
in a way to sort of make it fit, um with the
historical record. But the one I'm working
on now too, like I said is a woman who'd been
in a violent marriage, so she has to go through
some pretty awful stuff and writing that is
hard. Um, even though it's in the service
of the story and I'm going to save her from
that, I'm going to get her out of that situation,
but writing that stuff is definitely emotional.
Yeah. It's like you have all these multiple
personalities and you have to carry them around
with you every where you go. It's a weird
life. [laughter]. It's a very weird life.
So, yeah.
[pause]
>>How, um like how tied to the history do
you feel like you have to be when you're writing?
Kelly: That's hard, um, that's a good question
too. And being, um when you write about a
real person. Basically, what I did was I chose
a summer. 1855 is a summer we don't know that
much about what they did, so I purposely chose
that, because I knew that would give me the
space to create this. But I knew, we know
what happens, you know in the spring and we
know what happened in the fall. So I knew
it was, you know, start with that and I could
create in between and then I would have to
join back up. It was kind of fun, it kind
of gave me just like you know, Robert Frost
has that saying, um free verse poetry is like
playing tennis without a net. You know if
you don't have a, a structure to your poem
or your story then, anything goes, and how
hard is that? You know and, and that's a,
well, I don't really agree with that because
there's other things that are hard about that.
But this gave me a structure that, you know,
I knew how it had to start, and how it had
to end, and the fun part was, how to get them
to that point. Um, but in terms of I do want
to be accurate in the way that I portray the
carriages and the clothes and the way that
they looked. I don't want to say that they
got on a train in this town if there wasn't
a train in that town yet. So, doing that kind
of research was, you know, hard, at times
to track down a little fact that you'd have
to go through ten different books to try to
find this one little fact and it would end
up being one sentence in the story, but it
was for my own satisfaction that I knew that
it was correct. But then there comes a point
where you can't find the answer and then you
just have to guess what it would be. Yeah,
and so.
>>Okay? Well, thank you so much for being
here.
Kelly: Thank you so much you asked such good
questions. It was wonderful, I love it. I'm
so happy. [laughter].
>>Well thank you for spending your time with
us and um feel free to take a book as you
leave.
>>Thank you.
Kelly: Thank you very much.